offenbar traurige gewissheit beim fall
der geister chestnut von der sie heute
vormittag vielleicht schon gehört haben
vor der libyschen küste stürzt ein
flugzeug ab eine cessna und das
tatsächlich vor den augen von
kampffliegern an bord soll auch peter
griese mann gewesen seinen ehren
präsident der blauen funken in köln mit
an bord ebenfalls auch seine frau
juliane tochter lisa und ein
familienfreund diesem an dem auch eine
charterfirma für privatjets gehört soll
die maschine selbst gesteuert haben und
grund für den crash vor der küste
lettlands wahrscheinlich
treibstoffmangel
familiendrama im flugzeug ein
kleinflugzeug eine cessna 551 ist auf
dem weg von spanien nach deutschland an
bord eine kleine familie mutter vater
tochter und der pilot nach dem start
meldet die maschine druckt probleme in
der kabine dann bricht der kontakt über
spanien ab spanische und französische
kampfjets steigen auf wollen die lage im
privatflugzeug überprüfen sie versuchen
funk kontakt herzustellen vergeblich
können im cockpit und in der kabine
niemanden sehen sind die insassen wegen
der druck probleme bewusstlos die
maschine soll eigentlich in köln bonn
landen kommt da war vom kurs ab am
fliegerhorst in rostock steigen zwei
deutsche eurofighter hoch um die geister
cessna zu begleiten hinter rügen
begleiten dann dänische kampfjets das
flugzeug doch die maschine gerät ins
straucheln und stürzt ab
jetzt versuchen die schwedischen
behörden trümmerteile des flugzeugs zu
bergen für die insassen so ein sprecher
der schwedischen küstenwache gebe es
keine hoffnung mehr
[Musik]